[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español los franceses se elegirán
presidente de la república el próximo
mes de abril tradicionalmente francia se
refiere a los países de américa latina
como un aliado importante más aún a
partir de la presidencia de sal de bolt
se volvió una tradición no escrita que
los presidentes en turno visitaban por
lo menos a algún país de américa latina
esta tradición se ha roto desde la
llegada del presidente emmanuel macrón
como presidente de francia dado que
probablemente sea reelecto presidente en
las próximas elecciones nos preguntamos
cuál puede ser la evolución de las
relaciones precisamente entre francia y
américa latina para hablar de ello
contamos con la presencia de yangjiang
klinsky que es director del observatorio
de américa latina de la fundación jan
yúnes y asimismo también investigador
del instituto de relaciones
internacionales jean jacques bienvenido
a esta escala en parís gracias por la
invitación gracias por acompañarnos
antes yo quisiera hacer una precisión el
presidente en manuel macro me hizo una
visita a finales del año 2018 argentina
en del g20 es la única visita que hizo
pero no fue una visita con presidente en
el protocolo de visita de estado que es
lo que explica cómo entiende usted que
se haya roto esta tradición que decíamos
se estableció con charles de gaulle el
presidente desde están el presidente me
tengo que ir a todos los presidentes
visitaron américa latina salvo el
presidente en manuel macro y sarkozy
visitó muy poco américa latina citó
también pero visitó pero poco en
generación los otros efectivamente si
uno las cifras cantan consola donde
visitó diez países
en forma bilateral
y el presidente actual de manuel marco
efectivamente como usted lo dijo visitó
solo una vez un país latinoamericano
argentina pero no lo visitó en forma
bilateral a pesar de que hubo un
encuentro particular con el presidente y
mauricio macri pero fue porque era el
turno de argentina como miembro del
grupo grupo g20 de organizar esta
conferencia
internacional
lo que no quiere decir que el presidente
no se interesa américa latina recibió a
muchos presidentes latinoamericanos
de méxico de colombia y perú de
guatemala de argentina muchas veces
colombia también dos o tres veces
recibe pero no visita entonces
efectivamente uno puede plantearse por
qué qué pasa yo diría que la era una
coyuntura muy particular
después de la en estos momentos
especialmente ahora con la crisis
craneana pero hubo otros elementos más
urgentes para la política francesa
américa latina siempre es el último de
la cola para francia cualquier sea el
presidente con la excepción
efectivamente llamativa del general de
gaulle y de fonz omitieron que tuve que
incluyeron americana tiene en su visión
del mundo los otros hicieron una
presencia porque france miembro
permanente del consejo de seguridad de
seguridad bueno en el caso de emanuel
marco se centró esencialmente
porque no había la coyuntura le imponía
de áfrica
rusia china
eeuu euro unión europea
olvidándose efectivamente de américa de
américa latina hay dos datos que han
llamado mi atención jan jan culinarias
que primero en su primer año de gobierno
el presidente manuel embargo emanuel
macrón realizó 55 desplazamientos al
extranjero en el primer año de gobierno
y sólo en lo que comentábamos jugó ese
desplazamiento a buenos aires en el
marco del g20 estuvo ahí seis horas y se
regresó pero más importante aún cuando
uno ve la lista del equipo más estrecho
de consejeros del presidente no hay un
consejero para américa latina hay
consejeros para áfrica hay consejeros
para asia y oceanía y hay consejeros
para europa para europa continental para
medio oriente américa latina existe si
es el consejero de asia que tiene bueno
américa latina en un cajón pero en la
época de holando pasaba lo mismo de la
época de sarkozy también
bueno es una tendencia
pesada
que viene de lejos
yo diría también que américa latina
tiene en cierta forma la culpa hubo un
intento de tener
una cooperación muy fuerte con brasil
que empezó en 2008 en la época de
sarkozy john coughlan bueno con el
presidente actual de brasil
bolsonaro que completamente para el
francia
bueno no no es el país central el país
importante para el país el más
importante es estados unidos y
eventualmente rusia acaba de visitar en
miembro del grupo bric acaba de visitar
al presidente putin en plena crisis e
internacional y yo diría que
la relación con francia tomó
una dimensión polémica muy fuerte
tocando la esposa del presidente francés
con las críticas personales que es
totalmente insólito del presidente
brasileño entonces que este elemento que
era el elemento fuerte en los últimos
años de la relación con américa latina
cayó si podía decir el otro país hay
otros dos otros países miembros del g20
méxico argentina y messi argentina está
en una crisis de larga duración
financiera no está en capacidad de tener
un papel importante
siquiera en américa latina y méxico
tiene un
presidente actualmente que no viaja
ciertamente
entonces a nivel internacional siempre
hay un mínimo de reciprocidad entonces
es muy difícil armar una cooperación
estratégica
yo diría con méxico sin que hay un
compromiso personal de los presidentes a
pesar de esto yo diría que hubo un
intento de tener una relación fuerte con
méxico a nivel de los ministros de
relaciones exteriores y armaron algunos
proyectos sobre la multilateralidad
de la alianza a la alianza multilateral
que fue fundada con algunos países
-francia alemania sería una influencia
pero también con chile y méxico- y hay
un proyecto particular
franco-mexicano ligado a la igualdad de
género en una conferencia que tuvo lugar
el año pasado en marzo
en presencia del secretario de estado de
méxico y yo dije que hay otros proyectos
también ligando francés con méxico el
problema es que es un
iniciativa de este tamaño necesitan de
apoyo presidencial
y entonces su falta eso quita
peso a la influencia a la iniciativa que
podría tener que hubiera podido tener un
peso mucho más importante hay una cosa
que llama mi atención en jankunas que
hay elementos sin duda alguna importante
es usted lo mencioné está la cuestión de
género está la cuestión del narcotráfico
está la cuestión cultural están las
relaciones comerciales pero por ejemplo
en relaciones comerciales claro son los
tres países grandes de américa latina
pero están otros más de américa latina
américa latina en respecto al comercio
en francia peso hacia caso 5% y no más
es verdaderamente insignificante esto
pero a nivel local hay muchos intereses
de grandes empresas sólo en brasil hay
más de 6.000 empresas francesas también
en méxico parece que o sea da la
impresión que se ha perdido del
escenario américa latina para el
presidente francés bueno es también una
tendencia que viene de lejos
y el problema de la presencia china es
justamente al momento que francia y
europa pierden espacio en américa latina
eso deja la puerta para que los
intereses chinos se introduzcan y
después haya las críticas de que ustedes
están dejando entrar a los chinos bueno
hay dos teorías al respecto hay algunos
comentaristas europeo que considera que
europa y francia podría dar una tercera
vía una tercera opción los países
latinoamericanos que era la opción de
dogo los metieron en su tiempo el
problema es que hoy día la visión es
distinta la visión de china en américa
latina
es muy distinta de la que se tiene en
europa china para muchos países
latinoamericana y la opción alternativa
a eeuu y europa
cuando por ejemplo en la época de
presidente trans de eeuu hubo una
campaña trans mandó al secretario de
estado a distintos países
latinoamericanos para decirle que
cuidado a romper los contratos que usted
tiene con huawei
rechazaron
el presidente sebastián piñera que no se
puede decir que es un revolucionario
izquierdista rechazó y todos los
presidentes latinoamericanos van a china
porque china en el corto plazo ofrece
inversiones ofrece dinero
e integra a los países el último fue
argentina que entregó en la
la franja de seda
la iniciativa la iniciativa de la sede
son muchos países que son
quienes participan reuniones de la celac
organiza toda una red articulada de una
red de compromisos y apoyado con
presencia del ministro de presidente del
primer ministro contactos regulares
que permite entender por qué como en
áfrica china ahora es el socio más
importante de muchos países
latinoamericanos y los europeos que
bueno para algunos comentaristas que
podían ofrecer una tercera vía me parece
que se equivocan porque el país
latinoamericano no considera que europa
en este momento sea mejor solo que puede
sustituirse a china excepto méxico pero
por la relación con eeuu por la relación
con eeuu
ofrece otra opción
es
aparecer como un nexo entre el
latinoamericano eeuu para sustituir sea
la relación con china una pregunta
porque el tiempo se nos va rápido o jean
jacques chirac y son como quiera casi
680 millones de habitantes en américa
latina
decíamos muy probablemente el presidente
en manuel macro no sea reelecto para un
segundo mandato pero al mismo tiempo
cuando uno ve los programas de los demás
candidatos a la presidencia francesa
salvo uno
es el candidato me lanzó el resto igual
se ve que no conocen ni siquiera la
región hay siquiera mera opción y adele
y su programa habla poco de américa
latina y algunos elementos relativos a
los departamentos de american y podría
integrar algunos espacios
regionales pero poco me imagino porque
fue criticado por marco en la campaña de
anterior porque proponía una una
integración de los departamentos
ultraman al alba entonces que fue
criticado efectivamente por el
presidente saliente pues lamentablemente
no se ve que vaya a ver perspectivas de
mejora aún en un segundo mandato del
presidente francés estamos llegando ya
al final de esta escala en parís no me
queda sino agradecerle a yang jianjun
yasky presidente del observatorio
américa latina de la fundación yang yong
es su presencia en nuestros estudios
gracias por haber venido a ustedes les
damos una cita la próxima semana aquí en
otra escala en parís
[Música]